>> Greg: CNN'S ADVICE?
SKIP THE OLD SPICE.
YEAH, THE NETWORK THAT SAID EAT
A CRICKET NOW THINKS HYGIENE IS
WICKED.
[LAUGHS]
THAT ALMOST RHYMED.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO A CNN.com
ARTICLE PUBLISHED THIS WEEK
TITLED "DO YOU REALLY NEED
DEODORANT?"
EXPERTS WEIGH IN.
YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT, EXPERTS.
I AM NO CONSPIRACY THEORIES BUT
I THINK WHEN IT COMES TO WEARING
DEODORANT, IT IS BEST TO DO YOUR
OWN RESEARCH.
THE ARTICLE POINTS OUT THAT
THERE'S ACTUALLY NO MEDICAL
REASON TO WEAR DEODORANT.
WITH ONE DOCTOR CHALKING IT UP
TO THE FACT THAT "WE LIVE IN A
SOCIETY WHERE BODY ODOR IS NOT
UNIVERSALLY ACCEPTED AND THE
STIGMA SURROUNDING WETNESS OF
THE CLOTHES BECAUSE OF SWEAT."
REALLY?
STIGMA?
UNLESS I AM MISTAKEN, THE ONLY
PLACE BODY ODOR IS UNIVERSALLY
ACCEPTED...
[APPLAUSE]
DO I EVEN NEED TO FINISH THAT
SENTENCE?
PLUS, SAYING IT'S NOT MEDICALLY
NECESSARY ISN'T A GOOD EXCUSE
FOR NOT DOING SOMETHING.
TAKE IT FROM A GUY WHO TRY THAT
WHEN A COP ASKED HIM WHY HE
WASN'T WEARING PANTS IN A
BENNIGAN'S.
I LOST MY LUGGAGE.
SAM BRINTON STOLE MY BAG.
WHY WAS THIS ARTICLE WRITTEN?
IT SEEMS LIKE AN ON THING.
>> Kat: MAKES PERFECT SENSE
WHY IT WAS WRITTEN.
CHRISTMAS.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
>> Kat: YOU.
NOBODY WANTS TO DO ANYTHING
BECAUSE IT'S CHRISTMAS.
THE PERSON HAD TO WRITE AN
ARTICLE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO WRITE
ABOUT.
I DON'T WANT TO THINK.
THEY ARE LIKE OH, DEODORANT,
OKAY.
THEN THE EDITOR WAS LIKE, I
DON'T GIVE A [BLEEP]
EITHER.
SURE, RIGHT ABOUT DEODORANT.
NO ONE WILL READ IT ANYWAY.
>> Greg: IT'S WEIRD.
YOU DO SEE A LOT OF STRANGE
ARTICLES AT THE END OF THE YEAR.
IT'S LIKE PEOPLE MAILING IT IN.
TYRUS.
>> Tyrus: PHONING IT IN.
THEY KIND OF GAVE TWO REASONS
WHY YOU WEAR DEODORANT.
BODY ODOR AND WETNESS.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A CURE FOR
THAT.
APPARENTLY IT WAS RIGHT UNDER
THEIR NOSE THE WHOLE TIME.
IT WAS DEODORANT.
>> Greg: WHAT THEY DO BEFORE
DEODORANT?
>> Tyrus: IF YOU'VE EVER BEEN
TO PARIS, FRANCE, IN THE
SUMMERTIME, YOU KNOW.
HAVE YOU?
I HAVE.
YOU ALL KNOW.
YOU'RE TOO SCARED TO SAY IT BUT
YOU'RE FLYING TO DO STORIES
ABOUT BIG BOOBED PEOPLE BUT NOT
TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT BODY ODOR
IN FRANCE.
>> Greg: INTERESTING POINT.
PEOPLE WHO SMELL ARE GOING TO BE
THE NEXT PROTECTED CLASS.
YOU'RE NOT HIRING ME BECAUSE I
DON'T WEAR DEODORANT.
>> Matt: THERE WAS THIS WHOLE
THING, THE FAR LEFT GOT TOGETHER
AT SOME CONVENTION AND THEY GET
TRIGGERED BY PEOPLE THAT CLAP SO
YOU COULDN'T CLAP.
>> Greg: YES.
>> Matt: BODY SMELLS WAS A BIG
PART OF IT.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO IDENTIFY AS
NOT WANTING TO SMOKE ALONE SO
YOU CAN WORK ALONE IN THE
COLOGNE PEOPLE HAD TO STAND
SOMEPLACE.
IT WORKS OUT, AS THE POLITICAL
GUY HERE ON THE PANEL.
I THINK IT'S A BREATH OF FRESH
AIR COMING FROM CNN.
THEY ARE NOT LYING ABOUT TRUMP
OR REPUBLICANS OR ECONOMICS.
I THINK THEY SHOULD STAY ON THIS
FOR A LONG TIME.
>> Kat: I AM SURPRISED THEY
DIDN'T GO WITH "IS DEODORANT
RACIST?"
>> Tyrus: ALREADY ESTABLISHED.
>> Greg: THAT WAS MY NEXT
QUESTION.
SURPRISE!
SURPRISED THEY DIDN'T SAY
DEODORANT WAS RACIST.
HOW DARE YOU EXPECT THEM
MARGINALIZED TO SMELL GOOD,
DAGEN?
>> Dagen: EXACTLY.
THEY DIDN'T NEED AN ARTICLE.
THEY JUST NEEDED A HEADLINE.
CNN, IF YOU STINK AS BAD AS WE
DO, USE DEODORANT.
IT'S VERY BIZARRE BECAUSE WHAT
TYRUS WAS TALKING ABOUT, THEY
SAY, THEY GO INTO DEODORANT'S
NEUTRALIZED BODY ODOR.
ANTIPERSPIRANTS REDUCE WETNESS.
BOTH ARE OFFERED IN ONE PRODUCT.
IS THAT WHAT THEY THINK OF THEIR
AUDIENCE?
THEY NEED AN EXPLANATION?
AND THEN THEY ARE LIKE, THERE'S
NO RIGHT OR WRONG ANSWER WHEN IT
COMES TO YOUR PERSONAL
PREFERENCES.
YES, [BLEEP].
IF YOU SMELL LIKE FUNYIONS AND
FEET, YOU NEED TO BE USING
DEODORANT.
>> Greg: THE WORST PLACE IS
ALWAYS A PLANE, WHEN YOU'RE
TRAPPED.
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
IS A MOST LIKE TIME STANDS STILL
WHEN YOU'RE IN AN AIRPLANE NEXT
TO SOMETHING SMELLY, SOMEBODY
SMELLY.
HE CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
AND THEN YOU'RE THE SUSPECT.
>> Kat: I WAS ON AN AIRPLANE
WI